it's a baseball fan this is what you
want to see fernando tatis junior going
against mike trout both have been
outstanding so far the seat as far as
the home runs the rbis i just love the
fact that these two are going to be
going at it in a real game scenario
exhibition games or spring training
that's fun but this is legit you
mentioned julio tehran is on the mound
for the angels this will be his sixth
appearance lilo tehran has faced the
padres 12 times in his career 12 starts
five and four three point eight juan era
nelson lament for his eighth start of
the year for the padres tonight and
having a really good season this 28 year
old making his eighth start nice record
above 500 the era stellar
this one is popped up in the year back
at first hosmer drifting
will make the catch in fairground for
out number two
so they retired trout justin banning in
the clean up spot hitting 138 one double
four home runs and 10 runs bound it in
and it is grounded to short off the
backhand of tatis that's time to recover
and does good pick
by eric hosmer on the other side so he
knocked it down didn't feel too cleanly
and then the throw was in the dirt but
hosmer digs it out and upton is out
number one
so here's angelton simmons he goes after
the first pitch and bounces that one by
the mound and threw into left center
field he was first ball swinging
angel's first hit of the night simmons
came in with a little five-game hitting
streak so he's extended that and
now the batter will be joe adele so we
begin the third scoreless here at the
big a profiler was in the box then he
just stepped out now he's back in
this one is lined over the shift and
into right field of base head
and fifa was out there quite a ways in
right field but it's over his head in
front of adele and there's the first
base runner to reach on the first hit of
the night for the padres this was placed
perfectly as you mentioned don with the
shift scoreless game in the third inning
dangerous hitter approaching the plate
though and fernando tatis payoff pitch
and that's ball four running inside
second walk given up by tehran and his
outing second walk of the inning and
that loads the bases
here's his pitch that's a liner but it's
right at rendon the third baseman and
that is how the inning will end
so tehran pitches out of a bases loaded
jam and they leave all three of them on
bottom of the third coming up
top the order and joe hey on deck a
little hesitation 0-2 breaking ball gets
him
does he think he has johnny cueto yeah
when you're throwing 97.1 average
fastball and you have an unhittable
slider i i don't think you have to do
anything like this do you whenever we've
done these things where it's trial
versus ballinger trout versus yelich
trout uzi does something pretty special
in these games
1-1 hammered out to left-center field
that one is long gone big fly for mike
trout two nothing halos trolley always
loves those comparisons to the greats in
the game the young players in the game
and trout shows once again why he is the
top dog still going 424 feet
for trout lumet that second time through
a little bit better batting average than
trout
they could pay for that two out walk two
down hosmer at third and jerickson pro
far single to right field his first time
up in the third inning one of two padres
hits and he drives on to deep right
field back goes adele at the wall that
ball is gone
a two-run home run for jerks and profar
he ties the score at two to two with one
swing of the bat profar's sixth home run
and a padres uniform has tied this game
two to two so the padres do make tehran
pay and profar all smiles as he gets
high fives on his way back to the dugout
humpton's on the move little hit and run
action toward the corner
upton should come around to score pujols
on his way to second base has himself an
rbi double the angels are back on top
three two
love that seeing that from joe madden
having upped it on the move albert is
making good contact picks up a double
and another rbi for the machine two down
here in the fifth inning fernando tatis
junior
santee shooting one toward the corner
slicing away from adele and he'll dive
did he get it and hang on to it he did
wow what a play by joe adele
robbing tatis of extra bases and that is
the third out that's one of the best
angles i've seen from joe adele we saw
that one when he had made that good cut
off throw to anderson simmons but this
is a great angle for joe adele to run
this one down this ball gets and it
stays in that corner that's a triple at
least he's been working so hard on those
routes catch it and control it
when that baseball is in the glove and
the way he rolled his wrist and shoulder
and now we'll walk and
cadres have runners everywhere
now a fly ball headed to short right
field adele coming in now going back a
step he'll make the catch machado's
tagging trying to score throw plateward
will be late and the padres tie the
score sac fly for profar and it's tied
up three to three second and third now
two down and jason castro
this one is lined to right center field
and it's going to get down a gapper to
the track and the wall from third base
scoring is hosmer here comes cronenworth
two runs in for the padres they take a
5-3 lead
jason castro welcome to the san diego
padres puts them on top 5-3 in the
eighth
three running to this point
this one is to left field shallow up
then is not going to get there
one run is in here comes another for the
padres and they'll take an 8-3 lead two
driven in by manny machado and it's a
five-run eighth inning so far for san
diego
osmore's been aboard three times a walk
was hit by a pitch and singled earlier
in this inning now he drives this one to
deep right center field back goes trout
looking up and hosmer leaves the
building
it is a three-run home run for eric
hosmer and the padres taking a 11-3 lead
eric hosmer with his eighth home run of
the year and the padres put together an
amazing eighth inning in anaheim anthony
bemboom who is 043 the catcher for the
angels tonight
on the ground a short end tati slides to
his left throws to first and that will
end the ball game
now the angels do get a run in the ninth
inning but the padres win game one of
this series 11-4 in impressive fashion
they score eight times in the top half
of the eighth inning it was a tie game
at that point and they break it wide
open